[Music]
Comcast remembers everything
forth Matt Damon Bourne movie is still
checking if he remembers everything
which he doesn't because the movies keep
piling on more backstory that didn't
exist before highly demanded forth Jason
Bourne film somehow feels the need to
open with a drawn out previously on
Bourne recap Jason Bourne's greatest
hits the Clive Owen scene when he fought
that guy when he did this thing when he
was in the bathroom at one time when he
didn't kill that one dude when he looked
through the scope doing assassin things
in case she confused it for the Greek
city of semantics that is not on the
border between Greece and Albania so
it's come to this Jason Bourne
bloodsport what any of these people bet
the way they did if they'd seen the
wounds on his back with wounds make one
more or less inclined to back it like he
survived multiple gunshots must be a
hard-ass or look how many times this
pussy has been shot what a wimp
unfortunately the scene was better in
the trailer also even if this is a
small-time Greek underground fighting
circuit is this really the best way to
lay low I thought the square was a ghost
who could disappear whenever he wanted
and he's just one punch victory and
fools over here and in the news due to
financial crisis Greece I didn't lose 25
sins right now this movie suddenly
without warning became real steel - and
he started fighting robots in case you
confused it with some other video with
incompatible confidence years after she
went on the run from the CIA Nikki is
back to her natural hair color because
reasons and also it's Iceland I guess he
probably didn't know this but 5% of
Iceland's surface is covered in hi on
computer server rooms we introduced this
movies villain via Internet article also
just the mere hint of a crusty old white
dude means this is the movies primary
villain the Hall of Fame villain roster
includes Albert Finney Chris Cooper
Brian Cox Scott Glenn Dick LeBeau Keith
Richards and 40 years into the future
Channing Tatum - Niki hacks into the CIA
computer which of course has a folder
marked black operations right next to
the folders that say really evil and not
porn whoever it is just hitting their
Idol and thankfully my computer just
happens to contain a program that
visualizes slacker hackers a company to
access our they found it back to us
we need the reverse shell I'm going to
love hipposaurus and I'm going to go
ahead and award three more sins for this
technobabble bull scattered throughout
this movie right now she's using that
famous software adobe criminal finder CS
17 look at his face look at it she's
beautiful but she's young looking as and
she's supposedly in charge of all the
CIA's cyber whatever whose daughter is
she eight come on you can tell me I'd
like to be point on this operation
despite me being 16 years old that was
actually point on bringing you this
current data mission so I think that
qualifies me i embedded malware into
Parsons download you embedded malware
into her download but couldn't stop the
download I give you full operational
control on this even though you're 12
and also because I plan to Pam Landy
Raph and wrap this around your neck when
it goes sour and you're kind of stupid
for not realizing this in case she can
be used it for Rome Georgia but that
there is a Rome Georgia now people can
actually care in case she can use
difference Georgia weight is this movie
King with me are all its foreign cities
actually paralleled the US cities in the
state of Georgia the Jason Bourne
passport the most useless passport he
ever had and yet he still hangs on to it
for emotional purposes sentimentality
no reason but the viewers heartstrings
he wins one site with one punch but the
next fight we see he's basically even
with his opponent why because we need to
buy time for Kenickie to sneak into this
arena
Lucy sales to born in the first 15
minutes preferring his boxing career I
don't even know what these underground
fights are supposed to be how much money
he's making why he decided to do this
above all other things he could do I get
the feeling this is a metaphor for
Bourne hitting a low point essentially
doing porn porn porn the porn ultimatum
somehow Nikki knows when and where to
find born during his illegal underground
boxing matches sure she searched the
jean-claude Van Damme database where
borns fight was advertised with
full-color posters of the schedule okay
but which kiosk
taking a cue from Jack Reacher is there
a kiosk in Syntagma Square that stands
out as the kiosk and so why wouldn't the
CIA be able to figure that out as a
potential meeting spot the operation
we're about to see will involve two
teams on the ground tons of cameras
researching social media feeds and their
facial recognition software is God but
they'll somehow miss this meeting point
for just enough time to matter she's out
of respect to public transit system that
stays on schedule even during a riot are
supported a bus half hour go ahead and
west across that I know Nikki was just a
handler at the CIA but seems like she'd
be better at disguises I'm not getting
caught on cameras than she is in this
movie sir the asset has landed because
unlike previous movies we don't have an
asset in the very city is going down in
so he needed to fly it probably for a
detention
move it's amazing he knows this and she
still doesn't but she stayed underground
for like eight years right and Han zuman
enhance cliche what's that got to do
with me because it matters it matters
not freeze it right there that is not a
goddamn you enter lady that is bakery to
find all the matters is staying alive
you get off the grid survive by a
bare-knuckle boxing in Greece apparently
I mean I can think of a hundred better
ways to disappear and stay disappeared
and not draw attention to yourself that
are better than underground boxing
League Jason I came here because I found
something I found your father's name in
the headstone file and I'm risking my
life and yours because you just need to
know more about the Treadstone program
echo 3 movies which somehow failed to
bring up your father at any time also
don't you get the sense that Nikki and
Bourne could have met in the underground
fighting place and it would have been a
lot safer than there's public pool I
feel like this may be the dumbest
meeting place in film history
you don't know the terms about what they
did to you I came all the way from
Iceland to Greece because I really think
you need to get more stuff in the head
by learning even more truth about your
life Oh
buy me a drink or something thank me
it's a statue of Athena well hey wait
maybe back at that underground fighting
place or my apartment or somewhere
that's not called a statue of Athena
Marilyn Bond career to engage the target
if you think about it this Greek
financial right there's a great big
super convenience for Boris I normally
like Paul Greengrass action scenes
I think but try figuring out what's
going on in this one we got her nikki is
like the worst at this zoom in and hence
cliche on remote live feed handheld
cameras halfway around the world in real
time aka some bull suspect matching ones
description of so on a police motorcycle
you couldn't see that on your
omnipotence screens you had to get a
report about it
Yuma defeated that what comes to be
asset well at least in the last eight
years the CIA has learned how to
communicate with their assets in real
time other than text messages I'm
accessing Athens police tactical data
but only just now that information
wasn't useful to us prior to this moment
obviously I need eyes overhead bring up
the satellites another tool that was
obviously not useful in this situation
prior to this moment the targets will be
forced to turn away that satellite is
good you can see him in real time and
predict his route why do you even need
assets or agents in the field then why
did you assault born with regular field
agents for ten minutes before using this
magic it's absolutely astounding with
all the cops and protesters the phone is
able to ride this motorcycle through all
of it when I'm getting shot or napalm
hold on this this is the second time
McConnell has been shot to death while
riding in a getaway vehicle with boar
ever this time you won't lose sleep over
it because it's only Nikki and she was
never his girlfriend at least as far as
he can remember
also Nikki killed herself really she
aggressively went after Langley secrets
then went to deliver them to a known
expatriate in Greece during a riot she
knew she was going to die let's be
honest this is suicide by information
delivery
luckily nikki was holding her flash
drive in such a way as to throw it five
feet forward when she got shot so Bourne
could not only see it but actually pick
it up without himself getting shot so on
who was in an alley the asset has
covered and CIA helicopters are flying
around manages to disappear any way
through the magic of the movie not
giving a about showing his escape his
location Christian disowned yes sir if
he was working with Nicky Parsons we
will leave to suggest more maybe I mean
wouldn't hurt I guess but not likely
does he really know we're born is or
would lead them to it just asked at home
for yep they have a terrible history
together we're born helped the team of
11 thieves steal the Faberge egg that
the asset thought he stole after a
series of gymnastics through a security
laser grid he was called the night fox
that again and this happens a lot in
Bourne movies but the CIA has all these
cameras everywhere looking for facial
recognition hits on Bourne but somehow
can't find him when he use his mass
transit like this and he's not wearing a
disguise not only is that stupid that
stupid Bohr walks around in public
places without one bit of concern Shadle
of these journals people keep in movies
where they draw helpful pictures to form
connections rather than simply writing I
think ironhand has something to do with
redstone looking at this journal somehow
triggers a flashback does something
borns never thought about before lauren
sees these numbers and is able to simply
type them into a google search which
gives him the exact coordinates he needs
now what kind of code is that anybody
with any kind of spice parts would be
able to figure that out so why not just
write it out like a normal person or
simply come up with a better secret code
also Google is scary like way too scary
if I type these numbers at BER into
Google it only comes up with stuff about
this movie and something about the South
Dakota legislature which has something
to do with income tax on banks and
financial corporations so let me just
tell you when you come to deep dream
when you use our service no one will be
watching you everybody in this place
believes there's also not a thing people
with standing ovations basic app privacy
is not so new or revolutionary as to
create cheering crowds a standing
ovation because your social media app
doesn't share data the world is movie
living in again characters who would
benefit from not meeting in a public
place do so anyway Aaron is a known face
to millions of people and here they risk
being heard about their arrangement
there are better ways to do this right
in case you can used it for Berlin
Georgia
there actually isn't a Berlin Georgia
well now I'm confused I'm glad we could
get this garin's entire walk up to his
apartment gave me great insight into his
character on so I guess these guys have
crossed paths before born and Christian
together again so I'll call this meeting
born-again Christian it's what my pawns
101 teacher would want it's an address
slang for Christian the stuff
you mean you guys have an address linked
to this guy and you're looking for him
and you didn't think to check what is
basically his apartment as I found in
the room the guy who's researching the
government and health stuff it is
decides to keep a cell phone on him that
can easily be accessed I hate use if you
delete the file hacking a phone in a
room to delete files from a totally
separate computer that is in the same
room cliche you say that's another
cliche all right but is it even possible
considering how much bold he's had to go
through the last three movies to learn
tidbits of information about his past
this is a godsend of a computer that has
all the information possible on it Boren
has statistically already hit the
lottery six times in this movie alone ah
gah Matt Damon rocked one takes a king
dumbbell to the face and doesn't have a
caved-in face the rest of the movie or
even a parent major damage of any kind
Colin do you wants to call born in order
to stall him while Dewey's team moves in
to kill it honestly not sure why they
even bother deleting the files or
calling him now to alert him to their
presence they could have let him sit
there and search those files for as long
as he wanted while a team moved in
killed it then delete the files but they
decided the best option was being
assholes this nine year old CIA boss
commits beyond Snowdon level treason in
the Situation Room by texting born
directly also the fact that no one in
this room immediately stands up and says
sir text message sent Sabourin detected
it originated in this room you know it's
a great idea standing right next to a
door when someone you're chasing could
run out of it at any minute no chance
for anything bad happening there also
the powers that be decide we'll just put
one guy at the exit what's the point of
overkill when we're trying to stop the
most lethal assassin in the world Boston
sir but we got that Christian dassault
guy who was stealing our files and
publishing them so a bit of a win I
suppose or did they forget about that
guy in their blood left for born I was
born without file
desperately looking into his past and I
think he's ever taken point not only is
the seven-year-old a tech whiz she's
also a psychiatrist too paranoid if I
could get face-to-face with him I think
I can bring it back in there's
confidence then there's thinking you're
Jesus big gap in between ladies all of
that
even me off the books discussion I'm
honestly surprised they off the books
discussions were ever recorded in the
first place born still eludes the CIA by
taking mass transit no one was born
thinking about I owe somebody five bucks
I thought he was thinking about steak
and eggs also movie needs a transition
so here's born on a train having
flashbacks you love it I mean two of
those flashbacks are literally of him
looking at files on a computer a couple
hours ago so how can you not be
entertained in case you confused it with
London England yeah this is Jason Bourne
according to the documents Bourne looked
at he entered the Treadstone program in
1998 kind of amazing this guy who took
surveillance photos of born before then
still has the same office phone number
after nearly 20 years Portis called
Smith and it also went from day to night
and zero seconds it's no one going to
mention that what makes the CIA think
these guys with obvious CIA coms and
their ears are subtle you know after
watching Bourne mess with all these
panels to set a whole bunch of fire
alarms I wonder why he didn't just go
ahead and prepare this before he called
Malcolm by doing it this way he has to
do it while the CIA is trying to find
him after his call tipped them off that
he's in London unbelievable luck to show
up on the scene and three seconds later
spot the suspect Jesus this
five-year-old has incredible eyesight
and Lauren just happened to goddam spot
Heather in the middle of all this fire
alarm confusing - followed me to Beirut
now that time I saw my father
the problem with Lauren's passionate
demand for answers here is I just don't
know why he could at this point smoovies
having to set up anything about Bourne
and his father we didn't even get a
flashback sequence of them playing catch
in the front yard or anything - Costas
Wow Lauren takes Malkin's earpiece at
just the right moment - here do we say
something he has no business saying over
the radio right now
oh you you do not remember that guy
being around when your father died sorry
you don't your brain was not programmed
to remember every detail back then she's
like a strangely convenient place for a
wire to be but mostly I'm concerned with
how Jason crashes into this building and
survives this in case she confused it
for Las Vegas Georgia yep still driving
that Georgia thing into the ground get
off my back hate to harp on this every
time but now borns at a king airport
remember earlier in this movie they
basically went all in looking for Nikki
space to show up somewhere when they
were extremely successful doing so later
we find out they do get a facial
recognition hit but it takes two
freaking hours for it to be reported
here's this chair telling just King
landed doing some hacking to let born
through customs at the exact time he's
getting to customs convention kiosk
leaves extremely useful dark tags for
board to steal and using this movie
they're like little candies in addition
your grandmother's and oh look
covert cameras what a world we live in
in the next shot born we'll find a kiosk
displaying a dossier that shows what
happened to his dad also how is his
Convention named EXO Khan and not ex
machina Khan one drops the covert camera
into Heather's jacket pocket which will
later figure into the plot when her true
intentions are exposed but never once
will she put her hand down in that
pocket and find the camera somehow the
asset is only just now arriving despite
both born and Heather taking public and
private flights here and arriving way
before it what Heather even changed her
clothes already this asset is a terrible
travel agent how is the CIA not noticing
or tracking her direct communication
with born in the last movie they knew
Landy was talking to him almost
immediately but here they're just not
paying attention
or not this guy out to get his gun but
well somebody come looking for him soon
and won't the CIA fear it's born he had
a partner too so you think in five
minutes everyone will be looking for
more he most foully fingerprints yet
again I'm left wondering how you take an
image of someone's on file fingerprints
and create an actual something that you
can leave that same print at a crime
scene it seems impossible to make the
jocular ingrown right now somehow the
asset isn't in position to kill calor
right now something I thought would have
been easy for him to do with all the
time that's passed but even if he just
got here why didn't he get here wait
earlier he doesn't need to synchronize
his movements with Dewey
it takes Bowen less than a second to
determine where the sniper will be which
is goddamn ludicrous even for Bourne get
the cars ready right now oh thank you
did this way this guy knows what's up
because he brought the script that
realized he's a bad guy who has a hotel
room showdown with Orin in the finale
and he saw supremacy
this card can smell Jason Bourne
otherwise his decision to run down this
hallway is a wild guess that magically
pays off by pays off I mean gets his ass
beat hey yeah hey you might be that guy
who just tried to assassinate a Silicon
Valley billionaire let me see if my hey
skills will keep this cordial orange
owes to a casino elevator and gets an
immediate opening that's lucky rabbit's
foot right there how did it get to Black
Knight so quickly the last shot I can
find with exterior lighting is this one
and its brightest outside and nothing
about the events we've seen since
suggest it took place over three hours
will be utterly wastes a standoff moment
between two of our finest living actors
basing it on well the book that is this
movie's plot point is two great actors
had a staredown and it left audiences
with the bare minimum of emotions Lauren
suddenly fails at bowling because this
movie needs to have it's ridiculous big
is wrong ex machina ex machina this
asshole is actively trying to get away
to escape if he chooses to assassinate a
SWAT guy in full view of everyone and
then steal the slowest vehicle in a
ten-mile radius holy this I lock between
adversaries is impossible god damn this
is making me angry
fYI when a SWAT man crashes into a Dodge
Challenger at high speeds nothing of
consequence happens despite the fact
that this would cause mass hysteria on a
Las Vegas Boulevard full of traffic this
movie is going to make it seem like
Bourne can keep following the asset at
high speeds without getting stopped or
crashing I've never wanted to compare
this series of movies to the Fast and
Furious until now I don't know what
Bourne hopes to accomplish in this car
considering what the SWAT vehicle just
did but he's trying I guess that's more
than I can say for Ben Affleck in this
situation Bourne survives this but he
especially survives this Jesus never
wanted to compare these movies too fast
abuse oh I have well carry on when one
comes out limping now so you'll take
note that he actually did get hurt but
in the next minute or two you'll do the
Jack Bauer thing and it look like
nothing ever happened
adrenalin man see sight scenes these
days geez or matt damon and vincent
cassell even here on the same day just
so everyone knows somebody left a
teakettle down here in the sewers Moore
never fights in a place that doesn't
have improvisational fight props it's
important to note that we're back in
Washington DC now because that means at
least a day is gone by since the stuff
in Vegas happened but now we're about to
get to a scene where Heather still has
that camera in her coat and Bourne gets
to have an extreme ways moment to send
us off to the credits a high 15 to find
out you don't need me
not a problem there are many other
agencies so it won't fly no blackmail
within a job interview people if they
had are gone until the next Bourne movie
invents a whole new white guy to be the
guy behind the guy behind the guy behind
the guy I've got my money on John
Lithgow qumar's must register on
emotional physical recovery six weeks
full psychological recovery six months
we go ahead you're an expensive weekend
in Vegas nothing forget it you know I
didn't know it's not like down I'm not
an issue
the fighting thirsty they're breakdance
fighting
[Music]
where does the FBI weigh in as a
cooperating witness or just say about
exposure to airborne contaminants I've
been acting a role maybe all my life of
thinking I've done more accomplished
more produced more than I have
I'd like us to go and update